un cours est à des lieues du corps de
squeeze j'ai un nerf coincé et j'ai la
voix cassée en plus de ça et là une
question essentielle vient nos esprits
qui s'intéresse je sais ce que vous
intéresser allez hop maintenant je vais
me les objets dans la poubelle
écoutez j'ai trouvé un président qui va
nous redonner foi en la chance en les
petits coups du sort qui font plaisir un
peu un jet à beaucoup de coups du sort
qui font pas plaisir en ce moment on va
regarder que font plusieurs never telle
midi holtz savalle dit il est cool parce
qu'il réunit deux choses que j'adore la
première c'est lé coup de chance des
vrais coup du hasard qui les ont menés à
une situation de ou far il ya vraiment
voilà les coups de chance et la deuxième
celle et perfect timing savez ce moment
où il se passe un truc pilou bon moment
qui fait que sa venue à quelque chose de
voir ces deux trucs j'adore voir sur le
net donc ça réunit tout ce que j'aime
donc j'espère que vous aller mais aussi
allons-y
alors on était à quelques secondes de
perdre notre maison dans un feu en
californie merci à tous les pompiers
[Musique]
ouah j'aimerais connaître la taille la
taille de la goutte de sueur qui avait
sur le front des proprios de la maison à
droite c'est terrible bravo les pompiers
c'est sincère on dirait pas mais
vraiment si sincère vous risquez vos
vies pour sauver des beaux jardins et
des vies j'espère ne jamais avoir à
faire de discours je sais très mauvais
j'ai réalisé qu'à la moitié de la partie
qu'il était assis juste devant moi c'est
génial [ __ ] mais ça j'ai jamais fait
dans l'avion y a personne qui veut jouer
à chaque fois et moi en plus c'est une
bataille navale tricheurs tricheurs
croyais à skis vous avait déjà utilisé
cette fonctionnalité que vous avez pris
l'avion pour ce qu ont pris l'avion il
ya des jeux là moi jamais mais je rêve
de trouver quelqu'un qui aimeraient
faire ça avec moi un complexe en plus
évidemment cook qui se propose en
mariage en même temps
[Musique]
à notre action doit être dingue
je pleurais pas je pleurais pas wow wow
c'est pas dans ces vidéos là on est
censé pleurer calmez vous la probabilité
est si faible je suis pas ce genre de
personne qui dit ça mais quand même là
c'est un signe quoi ah bah oui ils ont
fait la pole aux bons un béluga sauver
un iphone ça n'a aucun sens ça me rend
fou
[Musique]
non mais déjà tu as la chance de croiser
un [ __ ] de béluga qui te sourit et en
plus ce belga le ramènent leur iphone
tous tombés dans l'eau mais comment on
n'a pas la même vie c'est un trick shots
dans le suspense pour un truc stif
j'adore j'adore créer du suspense autour
d'un lancer de tranches de cheddar sait
on fait ce qu'on peut
même le chapeau a fait un flip elle est
complice incroyable messieurs à ce
niveau de symbiose avec ton couvre-chef
quoi [ __ ] mais nous on essaie d'être
stylée de mettre un tee shirt un peu
bien et tout est déjà ils font des flips
leurs casquettes suis quoi il fait la
même figure
ça me rend malade un streamer sur ppj
tire une balle de sniper pour tester un
bug et tue accidentellement un mec qui
était à 400 m on n'a pas les mêmes game
[Musique]
mais comment évidemment il fait sa tête
mais comme ça me fait penser à l'époque
vous ce n'est ceux qui jouent à call of
on lance est tous des couteaux de lancer
au cros map au hasard en espérant tomber
sur un gars ça m'est arrivé une fois la
rédaction et sur youtube
j'aurais pu être dans ce vrai dit une
boîte en polystyrène retourne dans le
van deux fois de suite
quoi mais comment une interview pour ça
il ya un gars qui a été interviewé pour
ça alors quel est votre ressenti quand
je veux dire cette boîte de polystyrène
est retourné deux fois dans le van
qu'est ce que j'avais ressenti en
regardant votre rétroviseur dit nous ça
fait rire que moi peut-être j'assume
entièrement voulez voir un tour de magie
mais ça c'est du rail timing c'est
incroyable j'adore une équipe de la
croix-rouge a accidentellement capturer
météorite en vidéo mois en plein jour la
lumière que ça fait comment ça doit être
dingue de nuit et il a même pas vu il a
même pas profité il a découvert ça après
dans les rushes il va être des john
coffey attrape une bière alors je sais
pas qui est john coffey mais je sens que
c'est un mec bien plus stylée que tous
les mecs là qui regarde cette vidéo - y
compris je le sens
[Musique]
deux phases i et après vous pensez que
vous et moi on va séduire des gens en
fait ce qui me rend fou c'est pas le
fait qu'il a attrapé une bière et qu'il
aboie et tout est ouest il s est fait
qu'ils sont bas les couilles il fait
comme si c'était normal c'est dingue
c'est insolence moi ça m'arrive gros je
vai hurler sur les gens qui sont là
devant moi pour la dire vous avez vous
avez vu ce que j'ai fait n'est pas vous
êtes fier de moi peut-être que c'est
pour combler un manque d'amour certain
que j'ai eu un bon dos et ma vie
peut-être oui mais mais n'empêche c'est
un mec a attrapé un téléphone qui était
tombé d'une poche en direct d'un roller
coaster à 134 km heure quoi
[Musique]
mais comment je lui en veux pas il n'a
pas été insolent il a pas fait genre
c'était normal il a regardé sombre au dr
lui en mode mec 5 watts ce qui va se
passer
tu vois là on est sur une réaction
normale il a célébré un peu ce truc
incroyable qui vient de se passer du
coup ça lui retire un peu de charisme
par rapport à l'autre donc on est un peu
moins jaloux vous et moi et on le vit
mieux voilà on fait un peu de tout sous
le givre dans cette vidéo wat en dé quoi
ils ont un jeu ils font rouler une pièce
il souffle tous dessus pour que cela
fasse le tour de la table et que ça
arrive dans un truc mais ça ça s'est
passé pendant le confinement c'est pas
possible autrement
non c'est beaucoup trop d'énergie
investi dans un objectif pas ouf pour
que ce soit hors confinement non je me
trompe ils font ce qu'ils veulent mais
je pense c'est le confinement invoqué un
ami qu'est ce qui se passe c'est une
poubelle
[Musique]
elle a libéré son amie elle près de la
fuite elles en ont marre de travailler
gratuitement
si j'avais su être ému un jour par une
poubelle il ya un golfeur qui fait un
trou en un seul coup en dégageant la
balle et de son adversaire j'ai bref
j'suis désolé je suis fatigué à la fin
de semaine si compliqué sword me ht y
attend est ce qu'il est et les piles sur
la corsa bros est-ce que statistiquement
ça arrive à genre tous les humains une
fois dans leur vie d'avoir genre un coup
de l'ocm struggles à moi j'attends mon
tour
à part le truc de call of duty j'ai
jamais eu ça vraiment un béluga ramène
une go pro non mais là faut arrêter les
bélougas donc je suis désolé mais
attends ils veulent graillou je rêve
j'ai très peur actuellement rien que ça
c'est de la chance même s'il ramène pas
la gopro auquel vient de la faire tomber
dans l'eau
[Musique]
vek
et la récupèrent mais non mais et dire
au revoir avec sa nageoire on l'a vu non
mais c'est quoi cet être vivant c'est
dingue
il a le pouvoir des dieux va y avoir un
éclair au bon moment achim steiner
[Musique]
attends quoi attend c'est le truc de la
paella 50 à une paille et que tu
souffres pour que ça envoie le papier à
temps mais comment en vrai show vous
êtes beaucoup à d'avoir déjà vécu un
truc comme ça de foule chance avec un
pote et du coup c'est l'un des plus gros
fous rires que tu as eue ever avec ton
pote visé parfaite
[Musique]
mais comores mec si ça m'arrive avec un
ami je rigole pendante est six jours
consécutifs sans m'arrêter c'est
tellement incroyable rumba stacking au
j'étais ému par des aspirateurs robots
je crois je suis un peu sur les nerfs un
gars attrape son drone une seconde avant
qu'il touche l'eau à je connais ce
stress dans un fût signal de son drone
et qui va terrifier pas s'est jeté à
l'eau
[Musique]
j'ai jamais vu quelqu'un à porter
automne hiver
ouah il souffre hélas pour le pecq temps
mais marié vous mariez vous le pré
mariage homme robot un gars perd sa
compétition de rubik's cube à 000 une
seconde près non c'est trop triché de la
peine pour lui
[Applaudissements]
et c'est moi mais attendait depuis quand
un gars est autant emballé par une
compétition de big skull je suis désolé
tout le respect que j'ai pour le mix
cuba mais on dirait que michael jordan
vient de john key devant lui ses excuses
moi c'est ça le plus impressionnant dans
cette vidéo le meilleur sauvetage
possible ça à partir sur un mais comment
break mais comment ce qui se passe bah à
la voix dire qu'il prend feu muia ken
loo pompiers devant non mais c'est quoi
ce bon endroit au bon moment là c'est
dingue je veux que ça m'arrive s'il vous
plaît faites une pétition il faut que ça
arrive à chaque humain au moins une fois
un coup de chance comme ça on mérite
tous ici ce fou rire quand la vraie vie
à des sous titres ok en accident jyske
[Musique]
c'était pas le confinement c'est sûr y'a
que pendant le contenu de mon oncle et
gens tentent des choses comme ça c'est
sûr je suis content parce que le
confinement a donné lieu à ce genre de
vidéos jamais quelqu'un a essayé pendant
toute une journée de faire retomber le
bouchon d'un stylo du bien sûr stylo ça
n'a aucun sens sauf pendant le
confinement 1p magique à quoi ils ont
fait exprès les real soit possible allez
perfect timing mais jean sa main assez
incroyable wada geek mais c'est lé tout
les plus doux ça en fait les gars qui
font un move parfaitement raccord avec
l'overlay de l'émission c'est dingue
bon rien ne vaut le voilà le fait du
manque de talent mais ces eaux
j'ai des problèmes avec mon ordi il fait
ce bruit là
[Musique]
wright s'est terminée à ces horribles
maintenant on va tous s'attendent à
avoir de la chance là on va avoir des
attentes qu'on n'avait pas avant on va
vivre dans l'espoir là l'espoir qui se
passe un truc fou ça n'arrivera pas ça
arrivera qu'à un seul d'entre nous tous
ces bons d'ailleurs qu'ils bien frais
merci de regarder je vais me rétablir la
voie c'est promis j'ai adoré faire ce
petit ça brille ça faisait longtemps
qu'on n'en avait pas fait ma chaise
grince vraiment fort je vais la changer
c'est promis je mens je m'y engage
portez vous bien c'est ciao
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]